so let me set up this next segment for
you i already told you
chris wallace was likely on stage with a
contagious trump
during tuesday's debate based on the
timeline we
understand that in all likelihood donald
trump contracted coronavirus
either sometime between saturday and
monday of the previous week
and was likely contagious during the
debate as i already told you donald
trump was not tested at the debate as
most people
as everybody was supposed to be they
showed up late and were allowed
to use the honor system to tell them
trump doesn't have coronavirus
i already told you last week during a
stream that donald trump's family
immediately took off their masks at the
debate the only people
in the debate hall to do so even though
the rules were keep the masks on
so this weekend cnn fox news sunday you
know all of these different sunday shows
they tried to get trump administration
people on to talk about what's going on
no one agreed to do it except one senior
advisor to
trump named steve cortez who went on fox
news
sunday with chris wallace and it
devolved into
base utter lunacy that we really should
be studying and teaching our children so
they don't grow up to be like steve
cortez
let's start with chris wallace asking
why
doesn't the trump family think the rules
apply to them
with the masks and cortez is immediately
being deceptive not apply to them no
that's not the reality look
everybody was tested before that event
as you well know uh those of us who went
first were tested by cleveland clinic
directly everybody who gets on air force
one for any trip on air force one
is tested before they get on it doesn't
matter steve it doesn't matter everybody
that was in that room
was test steve everybody that was in
that room was tested
and the cleveland clinic's regulation
was it didn't matter
everybody except for the three of us on
the stage was to wear a mask
and people from the cleveland clinic
came over
and offered the first family mass
thinking maybe they didn't have them
they were waved away
and the commission on presidential
debates has issued a statement saying
from now on if you don't wear a mask
you're going to be escorted from the
hall
so chris wallace is rightly upset there
because
he and biden may have been exposed at
the debate
but when cortes says listen everybody on
air force one is tested remember trump
showed up too late to be tested
and they took trump's word that he was
negative
and now we know trump may well have been
positive at the time
and was almost certainly contagious
according to multiple doctors even on
the basic
facts this trump advisor
i don't know about camp but won't be
honest let's continue
so forget this question of being tested
beforehand everybody was tested
beforehand
that no i'm going to finish my question
everybody was told to wear a mask why
did the first family and the chief of
staff feel
that the rules for everybody else didn't
apply to them
chris we believe that masks are very
useful the president has warned them on
many occasions including visiting
the hospital where he's now a patient
when he was visiting as
commander-in-chief as a guest to visit
soldiers there he wore a mask we believe
in mass we also believe in some element
of individual choice people were
distanced
and they had been tested this is all you
know
me me me we believe in choice
we believe in masks those aren't the
questions the question is
the debate hall had rules why
why did the trump family just ignore
them now
there is shared blame here the first
family
should have been kicked out and it was
the debate organizers and the venue that
didn't do it and i understand that
that's a difficult thing to do would
have had
major pr repercussions despite being the
right thing to do now
the debate commission has been forced to
say if there are future debates at this
point we don't know trump is coronavirus
if you don't wear a mask you are going
to be kicked out
but the guy simply can't answer a simple
question
now notice what happens next when steve
cortez
can't get away from the question why did
they break the rules
he switches to attacking chris wallace
both of those things were true in that
now
they weren't distanced and there were
rules and there was no there was no
freedom of choice
they broke through i was there i was
there like you were and they weren't
distanced
why did they break not close together
look those chairs were not close
together and again we also believe that
people it doesn't matter
these are the rules from the community
they were close together steve and the
rules from the cleveland clinic where
everybody wears a mask why didn't they
just chris the way you're starting to
harangue me now actually reminds me what
you did to the president
during that debate on tuesday night when
oh yeah
no did you see what he did there he goes
after chris wallace he says listen chris
you're haranguing me just like you did
to trump
you unfair moderator from fox news of
course
when you lose on the facts you go ad
hominem
this is a very typical thing that
happens in debates
when people lose on the facts and it
continues
and chris wallace just re starts reaming
out steve cortez
and then he had he had to debate not
just joe biden but you
as well you are not a neutral moderator
then i don't mind tough questions i
welcome you know
reasonably talk questions but what i
don't think is okay is for you to become
the effective opposition to the
president
okay and those everyone there was tested
in the crowd they were distanced from
each other
people can make reasonable decisions for
themselves
no they actually they can't they're the
rules and they'll be kicked out next
time
steve let me just simply say the
president interrupted me
and the vice president 145 times so i
object to saying
i harangued the president i know it's
the talking point so the problem is that
while wallace
what what wallace says is true trump did
interrupt more than a hundred times
this is actually about the rules of the
debate hall
it's not what don jr's assessment of the
distance between
chairs is that doesn't matter and
unfortunately
trumpists will fall for this when you
ask trumpists
i haven't seen it done yet but based on
the vigil they held with no masks
outside walter reed over the weekend
if you went to trumpus and you said what
about this why did the trump family pull
the you know that's wrong they took
their masks off they would say
there was lots of space and we believe
in masks when people are crowded
together
but they weren't crowded to get it
together the people who claim to be all
about
law and order are going to say well you
know the rules
we decide if we want to follow the rules
or if the rules make sense or whatever
doesn't really sound like law and order
to me i assure you
they see this and they end up mad at
chris wallace
not at dishonest steve cortez the lying
trump advisor
not at the trump family for not wearing
masks not at trump for
making fun of joe biden's mask while
likely contagious with coronavirus
himself while on the stage now the
practical question is whether there will
be more debates this week wednesday
night is the
kamala harris versus mike pence vp
debate every indication is that's going
to happen
although they've agreed to more space
between
harris and pence on the stage i would
love to see kamala harris bring her own
uh plexiglas mike pence was at the amy
coney barrett super spreader event
sitting next to people who got the virus
i would be careful if i was kamala
harris
then we get to debates number two and
three for trump and biden
now the first one is scheduled for ten
days from today
uh trump has coronavirus as of today
that that's what we know you know what
they claim tomorrow i don't know but at
least as of today trump has coronavirus
trump's going to travel in 10 days or
even nine days if he's supposed to go
the day before
to a debate on an airplane
and again be on stage with joe biden and
the moderator
just 10 days after being in the hospital
for coronavirus
i don't see it so i don't know if the
idea is maybe they will go remote i
don't know
what the thought is at this point there
may be no more debate debates they may
be video conference debates maybe the
second one gets cancelled and they skip
to the third which is an additional week
down the line
17 days from today it's anyone's guess
at this point in time
we'll follow it and let you know as we
learn more about it